the great accomplishments in human
history were all preceded by a certain
degree of delusion roger bannister said
that in order to run a sub 4 minute mile
you have to be humble enough to do the
work and then you have to be arrogant
enough to think that you can actually do
it i think sir roger was dead on
what's your job at west point what do
you do
i direct a program of training and
instruction in the intangible mental
skills that are important for human
performance
the skills that allow one to be
confident even though there are setbacks
and difficulties in life
the attention skills that allow them to
stay focused on what's important even
though they're a heck of a lot of
distractions around us every day
and the skills that help us stay
composed and energized despite living in
a world of stress and demands
i have a staff of three trainers i work
with a lot of cadets individually in
small groups i give talks to various
athletic teams and various groups of
cadets within the organizational
structure of west point we've been doing
this work here for
over 30 years and
it has had expansive effects throughout
the united states army and there are a
lot of these same same skills being
taught um all over the uh north american
continent south korea bases german bases
it's important work
why do army cadets need that training
because they are engaged in preparation
for what could be the ultimately
stressful situation
combat where lives are at stake
where
property could be destroyed
where casualties are possible
so as important as it is for
emerging officers in the us army to be
physically fit
technically very sound
tactically very sound it's also
important for them to be mentally
tough
and
we
have paid lip service traditionally to
the importance of these intangible
factors confidence focus composure
etc but
30 years ago
west point decided that this stuff is
too important just to leave up to chance
let's formalize
a way of exposing our cadets to these
important principles and let's formalize
a
training curriculum
that will really help them get good at
it
rather than just
leave it up to chance and hope that they
get it you know through osmosis or
something else how does confidence
impact performance then
confidence at least the way i define it
as a sense of certainty that allows you
to be more or less natural and
unconscious in your execution doing
something complicated without having to
pause and think your way at each step
that certainty makes it easier for your
eyes and your senses to take in
all the important sensory variables and
stimuli that are in a situation
it helps your automatic recall from your
training and experience on what to do
with those
stimuli coming in
and then it helps your nervous system
deliver the right instructions
to your hands to your feet to your mouth
to communicate so it really facilitates
in the um most
accurate and
quickest and most effective behavior in
a stressful situation
it seems a lot like getting out of your
own way
absolutely you have to get out of
the learned tendencies that you've
accumulated over your life to worry
about what could happen to question your
own ability
about whether you can indeed execute you
have to get out of your own way you have
to get out of those thoughts because all
of those produce hesitation
hesitation
could cause your worst fears to come
true
is there a case that
less cognitive tasks
things that are more physical
are they
simpler for you to prescribe a
confidence protocol for what you're
saying is we try to not have too many
discursive thoughts we try to not
overthink the thing that we're doing but
if the task that we're doing is
fundamentally based on
thinking say some sort of logic puzzle
maybe it's something to do with like
coding perhaps versus something which is
a more physical trait is there a tension
or a difference there between those two
sorts of pursuits
a little bit of a difference but
much more
a common denominator
your your training in um calculus or
physics that you go through in order to
be able to solve a problem
is not all that different from the
training you go through to develop a
good cross-court backhand
or you know a good uh a good boxing
combination
the instructions to hit the forehand to
hit the boxing combinations are coded
into your uh into your brain and nervous
system the memory of the
thermodynamic principles and the
calculus principles are similarly
encoded into your nervous system
the tennis player has to trust your
backhand the boxer has to trust his
combinations the engineering student or
the medical student has to trust the
accumulated knowledge
so that that knowledge can express
itself on an exam in an interview
when you're dealing with a patient
just the same way that the tennis player
has to trust the backhand so there's
really so much overlap in consistency
across the
spectrum of human performance then there
are spec you know specifics or
differences between as you say a
physical task and a more cognitive task
is there a relationship between
competence and confidence
oh absolutely okay um
i'm the first person to describe human
performance as a function of both
competence the skill that you have
and confidence your degree of certainty
about that skill
you can have
tremendous actual competence
you know
consider the situation of a
athlete
who can do things in practice
but does not seem to be able to do them
in the actual match okay yeah i hit that
penalty kick nine times out of ten
oh and here's the opportunity for me to
do it when the crowd is loud
it's on television
and they don't hit it as well
okay well they have the competence
but they might have an episode of
self-doubt or worry or tent that
produces muscular tension which leads to
a missed opportunity so it's a matter of
matching up your confidence your
certainty about yourself with the actual
level of skill that you have
it doesn't matter that you can hit it
nine times out of ten in practice
if you have the self-doubt that reduces
that to five times out of ten in an
actual match
so it's a matter of
matching your belief in yourself
with your degree of competence as you
train in practice presumably though we
would want to actually be further ahead
of our competence we would want to
believe that we can overperform
absolutely um i'm telling people i don't
care how much practice you have had or
haven't had
you better be completely certain
that when you step onto that pitch to
play when you step onto that wrestling
mat when you step into that interview or
step into that room to take the exam
you believe that you are enough
so i love the way you put it you want
your confidence to just be a little bit
ahead of where you might actually be
and this is a this is an understanding
that
has enabled a lot of athletes and a lot
of performers to sort of turn the corner
and find that next level you know oh
i've got to practice i've got to get
better i've got to get better i'm not
good enough i'm not good enough now wait
a minute stop
i worked really hard
i'm not perfect
but i don't need to be perfect in order
to be excellent
and that's what i'm striving for
i can be excellent in this moment
dag on it i am enough
you talk about story from eli manning
can you take us through that
um
which story would you like about eli
manning chris i've got a dozen whichever
one you think's best
okay um
here's a wonderful story
this is the super bowl which in the
united states is the single biggest
sporting event of the entire year
more people are tuned into that than
unfortunately we'll watch the wimbledon
championships or um the european cup or
you know even the world cup so here is
eli manning in a critical moment toward
the end of the game his team is behind
and on the scoreboard they must score a
touchdown they are only four minutes to
play
they are not favored to win this game
eli manning steps back
from his own goal line and launches a
40-yard perfect rainbow of a pass to a
tightly covered receiver
drops it right into the guy's hands even
though there are two defenders marking
him very closely
that play moves the ball to midfield
that play sets up the
eli's team's winning touchdown and they
go on to win the super bowl
the very next day
eli is doing a nationally syndicated
radio interview
where the sportscaster asks him about
that particular play and he says
do you ever consider the ramifications
of failure at a moment like that
and eli being the very polite guy that
he is
gave a very polite answer
now consider that question
do you ever consider the ramifications
of failure at a moment like that which
means a do you think about failing
and b
do you think about all the bad things
that might happen should you fail
eli's answer was very simple
based upon all the work that he had done
to construct the right kind of
competitive mentality and he said um no
that's exactly what you don't
do
and i could you know i was listening to
this on the radio and i could sort of
hear the the sportscaster who asked the
question
kind of take a gasping breath back
because he had just been shot down eli
went on to explain
in a moment like that
you think about all the times you have
been successful
in leading a comeback
and he could rattle off four or five
games from that particular season
in his memory in which he had indeed
produced a comeback and a win
he says you think about these you recall
these moments and you forget about the
times when you didn't do it
you misremember those moments
but you hang on to the memories of
previous successes that produces the
feeling
which allows you which helps you execute
that is one of my favorite eli manning
stories well the bizarre thing is that
eli has this opportunity and so does
everybody else when you're talking about
envisioning what might come next in your
chosen pursuit you have the opportunity
to think about something
the fact that we have a negativity bias
and we tend to lean toward thinking
about how things might go
catastrophically wrong and how i'm going
to look totally stupid or i'm going to
flood my lines you know there is a
choice
you can choose to think one of any
number of things an infinity of things
you're choosing to think something that
is actively making the chances of your
performance worsening increase whereas
you could have thought of something that
would make it better
and you know i
it's when you put it like that when you
frame it as this is an opportunity cost
that you are giving yourself
to make your performance actively worse
because of the thought patterns that
you've inculcated and that you're
choosing kind of to continue to
um
pursue
it does make you feel a little bit
stupid forever having a negative thought
well
eli manning and a lot of other people
have
spent considerable time to truly
understand
how
the things that they choose to think
about
influences their emotional state
and that in turn influences the level of
muscular tension in the body
what's the science there must be a
science of of confidence how does it
biologically neurologically changes
well indeed as i mentioned before every
behavior that we have is produced
through a series of neural circuits
firing in a in a particular pattern
repetition of
the proper
actions and skills
physically refines
develops
optimizes those neural circuits
at the same by the same token
mentally rehearsing a proper action
mentally remembering bringing back into
consciousness the memory of a proper
action
similarly optimizes those neural
circuits
we can literally
change the configuration
of
parts of our brain parts of our spinal
cord and parts of our peripheral nervous
system simply by envisioning
now
it cuts two ways as you've indicated
if we linger on the memory of a poor
performance of a mistake of a behavior
pattern that
has not worked for us if we bring it
back into consciousness or actually
doing is refiring the neural pathways
that produced said behavior
oops
so it's very important and i love the
way you phrased it it's a choice
we have to choose to think about
how well we have done certain things in
the past and we have to choose to think
about how well we would love
to execute in a given future situation
and the degree to which we make that
constructive choice
literally
optimizes our nervous system
how about that
do the world champions and high
performers that you work with have the
same level of insecurity
and self-doubt that normal people do
in some cases absolutely let's remember
that these world champions and uh
you know olympic level athletes they are
human beings just like the rest of us
they've got
dreams
hopes
fears doubts worries just like the rest
of us
in many many cases they have been
genetically gifted with remarkable
capabilities height
a high degree of fast twitch muscle
um
wingspan in the arms okay so they are
ordinary people with a few extraordinary
gifts
but they gotta optimize those
extraordinary gifts by dealing with
their fears doubts worries just like the
rest of us
so one of the glaring misconceptions
is that you know
the confident people that you might see
displayed
by the media
are just naturally that way and they've
always been that way and there's
something genetically special about
their confidence that us mere mortals
can only hope to achieve
no
the reality the matter is when you see a
very confident athlete it's not just the
result of some uh
genetic predetermined tendency in that
individual it's the result of a lot of
careful introspection and the making of
that proper choice we've been talking
about over and over and over and over
and over and over and over again
so the good news everybody is that you
can develop confidence in anything you
want
don't think that you're locked into
having a certain amount of it it is a
skill it is a quality that you develop
and you can develop it in any particular
aspect of your life that you choose to
greg mcewen guy that wrote essentialism
he has this story where he always uses
this example and it really hit it home
to me he said the best performers in the
world that he's worked with ceos and
business execs and stuff so do you think
that they became successful and then
decided to be disciplined
or do you think that they decided to be
disciplined and then they became
successful and it's kind of the same as
it is a
it does feel quite circular thinking
about confidence and competence and
performance
and you think okay well
my confidence is led off the back of how
good i think i can be and then how well
i
managed to make that happen on game day
and then that feeds back into my
performance but
presumably if you can shortcut that and
focus on confidence in isolation that
means that you just constantly feed
potential and performance all the time
exactly right
the common misconception is that i have
to be very successful before i can be
confident
i would prefer as you put it to short
circuit that let's front load the
confidence
which leads to more automaticity in
performance and practice which is going
to lead to actual gains in our
competence which we can then feel better
about so your kind of kick-starting
catalyzing that whole
performance versus mentality uh
connection
where do we begin we're talking to
somebody who hasn't done any specific
work on confidence where do we start
people off
i start people off with
a very specific memory exercise
let's get control of how we think about
ourselves because
those thoughts are going to influence
our
emotional state which are going to
influence our body as we've been
discussing so i got to establish that
first
once we establish an awareness of that
thought emotion physical state
performance connection
let's get busy
being very selective about the right
kinds of thoughts
and i like to start with looking back at
your memories
i like to start with
looking at the memories that you've had
of indeed
progress and success
what are your top 10 moments
on the football pitch on the tennis
court
in the operating room in the board room
in the lecture hall presenting
let's go back and let's look at some of
the things that you have done that
create a sense of
optimism and energy and let's articulate
that
let's put that on a big poster in your
office
you need that those
uh sort of substantial seminal memories
are what i think of as you know deposits
that create a a mental bank account
psychological money
it's it's the metaphorical equivalent of
going down to the bank plunking down 10
checks and saying i want to establish an
account here here's my money
and then we follow that exercise with a
daily
reflection
on what we've accomplished what we've
done over the course of the day
and that daily reflection produces more
deposits into that mental bank account
and i urge clients to think back on
their day
at the end of the day before bed
and identify an episode or two
of quality effort
where did they do something that maybe
they weren't all that fired up about
doing it but they knew they had to do it
and they did it
you slugged through that email list you
you you
gave it yet another set on the squat
rack or the bench press
identify an episode of quality effort
and then identify an episode of a small
success
what did you get right
even if it's a relatively tiny thing
document that
that's a deposit in your bank account
and then take it one step further and
look for some indication in your life
over the last day or two of progress was
it what does it seem like you're getting
better at in a more general sense based
on your effort based on your successes
document that little bit of
progress yes i'm getting better at
identifying the core situation when my
team meets
whatever it happens to be that is a
maybe a five minute daily recollection
but it's bringing those
valuable memories into consciousness
that creates more of the certainty about
yourself
which leads to a more relaxed feel which
means to leads to muscular relaxation
better blood flow a wide open visual
field and that of course is going to
improve your odds of performing well
those are exercises that i like to begin
with
effort
success
progress
esp easy way to remember it
daily esp how long are you looking for
someone to write out a couple of
sentences a full paragraph just one
one little memory how does that work oh
it could be three or four words
it's not necessarily a paragraph
but it's the consistency with which you
do that
are you willing to look for the best in
yourself day by day
over a period of six months or a year
are you going to record that in a
journal or in a phone app or something
like that are you going to be consistent
looking for the best in yourself
actually deliberately building that
mental bank account day after day after
day to the point where you don't even
have to write it down anymore because
it's what you think about automatically
it becomes a mental habit
just as the physical habit of tying your
shoes became something that you
automatically did without having to tell
yourself how to do it
so that's how we can improve our
confidence on the positive side how do
people deal with negative self-talk
okay negative self-talk unfortunately as
part of human life
there is indeed something of a
negativity bias built into us as human
beings
because let's face it for the vast
majority of human existence on the
planet
our lives were rather uncertain
we did not necessarily know
where the food supply was going to come
from a month down the line
our existence was somewhat fragile and
unpredictable so we developed as a
survival mechanism this tendency to kind
of worry about stuff because it
energized us to be careful
okay
now
a lot of that negativity bias is
unnecessary but we still have it
and it's very important for everyone who
wants to become a more confident
individual to be honest about where
indeed does that negative voice
kick in
does it kick in when i enter the office
of my boss does it kick in when i enter
um the weight room does it kick in on
you know game day morning
when and where does it kick in
let's get let's get some awareness about
that
once we have that awareness now let's be
very good
at
talking back to that voice
again this is a choice that you make
this voice kicks in oh i don't know if
i've done enough practice
you have to acknowledge that you have to
acknowledge that right now your
confidence is under attack
it's kind of like you're in the boxing
match and here comes a punch
you better acknowledge it
and your second step after you've
acknowledged it is to stop it
everybody has the ability to shut that
voice off maybe you need to visualize a
stop sign maybe you need to visualize a
red traffic light
maybe and this is a somewhat humorous
example
you need to visualize a toilet being
flushed
we all know what
goes down the tubes there but that's a
representation of stopping it getting
rid of it
and then third
really important you got to get in the
last word
you've got to talk back to that voice
you've got to say no i have done this
practice and this practice and this
practice and this is where your
journaled mental bank account comes in
really handy
you can draw from it in those moments
and the same way you get the last word
in
during an argument
with your obnoxious older or younger
sibling
you get the word in against that
voice of negativity and fear and doubt
and that momentarily silences it gives
you an opportunity to be present with
what you're doing
now you may have to repeat that process
acknowledge it stop it replace it
two minutes down the road
you may have to do it over and over
again and that's fine
as long as you are acknowledging it
stopping it and replacing it getting in
that last word you are in the game
you're winning that mental battle
you are accomplishing what i refer to in
the book as a first victory
victory over your mind that gives you an
opportunity and please remember
all your competitors all your opponents
they've got just as much negative
self-talk as you have
if you're just a little bit better at
acknowledging it stopping it replacing
it then those competitors are those
opponents wow you just created an
advantage for yourself
so look at it that way gang that'll be
really helpful i love that i've been
thinking about this
i woke up in the middle of the night a
couple of days ago and had this
title for an idea that i've been
considering for a while so i'm going to
give it to you because i feel like this
might be your sort of thing so hedonic
adaptation is when
your consistent desire for material
wealth continues to move as you acquire
new and nicer and better things right
that's hedonic adaptation um i think
that there's an equivalent called
imposter adaptation so the imposter
syndrome which is when you do not feel
like you are worthy of any successes
that you are having in life and that you
don't feel like you're supposed to be
here i don't have the expertise that has
put me into the position i'm in right
over time
you can continue to
disprove your own imposter syndrome you
are put into a situation you defeat the
situation you come out victorious you've
done really really well and yet your
imposter syndrome continues to exist
you continue to beat it in reality and
yet mentally it is always there i'm
still not supposed to be here i'm still
not supposed to be here the way that i
see it if you continue to defeat your
imposter syndrome in the real world and
your imposter syndrome persists
after a while you have to admit to
yourself that this has got nothing to do
with your competence and everything to
do with the addiction to being an
imposter so this is the imposter
adaptation that i came up with that is
brilliant and that is absolutely the
case um i have not used that particular
terminology
but i have observed the same thing over
and over and over
um
an ice hockey player
you know
oh wow now i am playing junior
professional hockey in north america
uh
i gotta get used to this new level of
play
i'm not really comfortable
i get kind of comfortable
and on the basis of my success at that
level now i get to play at the north
american university level
oh once again that doubt that imposter
rears
his ugly head
and you have the same experience at this
new level you have to defeat it there
and then after your university
experience
you're invited to a to a professional um
national hockey league
situation organization oh do i belong
here
and i've even seen it persist once a
fella has made it through uni juniors
made it through university made it onto
a national hockey league roster become
the starter
on that roster once again there's an
adjustment and then once he even once
he's a starter oh i'm going to play in
the montreal forum a legendary arena
oh i'm going to play against
um one of the future hall of famers in
the league oh now i'm going to play in
the
playoffs at the end of the season each
of those steps in the career
reinvigorate
the tendency to feel like an imposter
like you don't belong and so you've got
to constantly keep working at it
at each level at each level at each
level in some ways it never really goes
away and this is what
you know again i come back to this don't
think ladies and gentlemen that
confidence is this all-encompassing
thing don't think that once you've got
it
you'll have it forever
there is no
atomic bomb you can drop on it to
destroy it
to destroy that enemy
it's a constant ongoing
war of attrition to use a military
analogy
so yeah that impostor
can continue to
lurk inside you and i love the way you
put it you got to realize that it's not
your competence that's holding you back
it's your own sense of self
so let's work on that let's really work
on being selective and careful with what
we remember let's really work on being
selective and careful and in how we
think about ourselves and our skill
level in the present let's be very
selective and careful about the pictures
we create
for the possible futures that we want
and let's make the right choices at each
of those levels
is there a degree of
delusion that's appropriate for people
in this case to try and well i don't
know whether delusion is the right word
you're selectively choosing particular
things that create a engender a certain
frame of mind moving forward i forget
the failures i focus on the successes i
forget the failures i focus on the
successes
in your mind is there ever a concern of
taking that too far is there such a
thing as overconfidence
i think there might be
but my experience
30 plus years of doing this work
29 years here at west point
is that there is a
far greater tendency
to be
under confident
to not believe in the actual level of
skill and capability that you do indeed
have
i can only count
on the fingers of one hand
the cases that i've encountered
where somebody was just ridiculously
inaccurate
in the matchup between their actual
skill level and their belief in their
skill level you know
to the point where they were
as you would put it over confident
that only becomes a problem
when
your level of confidence your belief in
yourself prevents you from doing the
requisite training
and
practicing you've got to have you've got
to be a workhorse for sure
but you want to match that with a
racehorse as uh i like to use the
analogy
to a certain extent getting back to your
point about delusion
i think there is a certain degree of
functional delusion that is very
powerful
again we use our imagination
to think about how we want to be
well we're not there yet so isn't that
by definition a little bit delusional
and
i don't think it's any stretch to state
that
everyone's personal breakthroughs
the great accomplishments in human
history were all preceded by a certain
degree of delusion
you know roger bannister said that in
order to run a sub 4 minute mile
you have to be humble enough to do the
work
and then you have to be arrogant enough
to think that you can actually do it
i think sir roger was dead on that
degree of arrogance i can do this well
that's a form of delusion
even all of us when we were young kids
trying to ride a bicycle for the first
time without the training wheels
okay
we couldn't do it
we had never done it before
but we yet entertained a certain
concept a certain idea
a certain vision
that we could indeed do it
and
without that
pre-existing vision
we never would have gotten back on the
bike after having
run off the road fall and scraped our
knees the first couple times that we
tried it
so yes there is a degree of functional
delusion which i think is very important
for human performance
i think you're right as well that
most people undershoot their confidence
as opposed to overshooting it the vast
vast vast majority of people that i know
are they're in need of more not less
indeed uh tony gwynn how did he work on
his performance
well tony gwynn is a hall of fame
baseball player who
during his years was probably the best
hitter uh in baseball
and he had a habit of looking very
carefully at the film of his performance
in the batter's box at the plate
but he did something very interesting
with it that i have used as an example
for what we all could do
he took that video footage
and he divided it into three
categories into three files in one file
went all the video clips of him hitting
the ball well
success
in a second file
he put the video
eclipse of him making a good decision
in the batter's box a good decision
whether to swing at the right pitch or
whether to hold off and not swing at a
bad pitch
and then there was a
third file
of his poor decisions when he swung at
the bad pitch whether he hit it or not
and once he had
broken down and edited his performance
into these three files
he basically just threw away the file of
him
making bad decisions
he did not need to look at that he did
not need to remind himself
of those mistakes as he put it
the last thing i want to do is watch
myself looking like a fool swinging at
somebody's curveball
so
those memories are selectively discarded
and the memories of him making the good
decisions
hung onto memories of him making good
contact with the ball hang on to that's
a way of selectively using your
experience to build that mental bank
account
is there not some lessons to be gleaned
from mistakes
certainly
you'll learn the lesson
but that's a relatively quick thing
once you've learned the lesson then you
can indeed throw away stop replaying it
in your mind stop replaying it yes i am
sure tony gwynn and boy do i encourage
everybody that i counsel let's look at
your performance let's look at the good
let's look at the bad let's look at the
beautiful let's look at the ugly
and let's make sure
what is there to be learned what is
there to be learned from your high
moments in this game and or this match
what is to be learned from your low
moments
and then let's translate those lessons
into positive affirmations and go
forward at that point
the memory of the mistakes serve you no
purpose
you need not dwell on them you need not
repeat them don't get seduced into
thinking that by replaying those
mistakes you're somehow going to be
magically fired up to become a better
performer
that is a comforting
illusion
but it does not work in the real world
what about people who want to be more
present during their performances
well isn't that what we all want to be
we want to be fully immersed in our
activity we want to be fully immersed in
the environment where we are so that we
are indeed taking in all the important
stimuli and input and responding to it
naturally automatically and
with greatest effectiveness
to get to that level of presence
the first thing we got to do
is cut out the discursive negative and
analytical chatter
and allow ourselves to become fascinated
by what's in front of us
can i actually become fascinated with
the
scalpel that i'm using to or the tool
i'm using to cut away that tumor from
the spinal cord
instead of telling myself not be really
careful you want to avoid this part you
want to avoid that part you better be
doing that just no
let's
just pay attention to what we need to be
doing
and that is the careful placement of the
tool on the right spot in the patient's
anatomy
if we're playing tennis what do we want
to pay attention to the flight of the
ball
the flight of the ball let's
determine ahead of time before we get
into that arena what is the most
important thing for us to
let our senses become fascinated by
the movement of the ball
the
flow of words as you're giving the
lecture
the body language in the audience that
you're speaking with
let's become fascinated with that
and let's allow our performance simply
to flow in that awareness
rather than keeping a running commentary
such as we might hear as we as we watch
the soccer you know a football match on
television well he's doing this here and
he's bringing this across and that was a
nice uh leading pass and oh look what an
excellent defensive marking and they're
really making their um you know their
case here you i'll first to control this
part of the pitch we don't need to talk
to ourselves like that
that interferes with our fuse our smooth
execution that interferes with our
ability to be present in the moment
how do we shortcut that discursive
thought in the monologue
through practice
if you want to be able to do this
in a match
in a presentation
well then you better practice being that
way you better rehearse
the state of mind
that you want to have
in a match
during part of your training period
maybe when you're working on a very
simple skill
you can be somewhat analytical about
your mechanics
but certainly once we get into a
practice drill or a training drill that
is more or less similar in terms of its
attentional demands to what we're
actually going to be dealing with in the
match we want to practice that same
degree of
decide what's important and allow your
senses to flow onto it and let's see how
good we can be with that and a
significant part of our practice should
be cultivating that game day mindset
that we want to have
that's the only way you're going to get
it
on game day
is if you practice it
because you know let's face it we all
settle
back to
the level of our training
when the chips are down and the
pressure's on we do not magically arise
to me you know new levels of competence
you know we see that in some movies
where the poor underdog hero is getting
pummeled
and then through some miraculous
you know
memory
he or she now sprouts wings and
emerges victorious at the end and the
violins play and everybody's happy um
okay that's a nice fairy tale ladies and
gentlemen but that's not the way we want
to prepare in this world okay let's
practice
the state of mind that we want to have
in the performance
because that what that which we practice
is what we are going to default to
at any point in a pressure-filled
stressful moment during the performance
i suppose the brutal thing to do with
confidence is that if you have
lowering confidence that causes further
worsening performances which then feeds
back into your confidence and then the
reverse is true as well which is why you
often see so my my housemate is the
physio for newcastle falcons rugby team
premiership premiership uh rugby team
and we go for walks and i don't follow
the team too closely but whenever he's
talking about his players that he looks
after he'll always say this guy's on an
absolute tear at the moment and this guy
everything that he touches is amazing
his body's feeling good he's rested his
kilometers and his chronic load is going
up per week and he's managing it fine
and he's nailing it and then it's the
guys who are struggling that are
consistently oh such and such had
another bad game this week and such and
such had another good game this week so
there is this vicious i think you call
it the sewer cycle and the success cycle
absolutely um we are all
in a way victims of how we choose to
think about our experience because our
thoughts about that experience again
create a mood state that mood state
influences our body and our body then
tends to reproduce the behavior that we
were initially thinking about and
worried about
and again it comes down to choice
how are you going to think about
yourself
the misconception is that well we have
to think about ourselves based upon our
experience
well only a little
i would tell you to think about yourself
based upon that
subcomponent of your experience
that makes you feel better about
yourself
even the rugby player who's
experiencing a stretch of bad games
would not have gotten to that premier
level of play
had he not a whole laundry list as we
put it in the states of powerful
experiences there are indeed matches in
his past where he
tackled beautifully moved the ball
beautifully ran with the ball
beautifully kicked the ball beautifully
it's up to him
to
dredge through his memories and get
those shining
nuggets of gold
right in front of his mind and that is
what will change him
what about challenges that are coming up
in the future a lot of the time let's
say that we've got
a cup final that we know is a couple of
months off or it's a speech that we've
been booked to give in three months time
or something how can people prepare
themselves they haven't got the
opportunity
to
perform and then reflect on the
performance because it's going to be one
big thing
it's going to be one big thing
and the choice that you have as you look
toward that one big thing
is whether you are looking at it with a
sense of eagerness and excitement
or whether you are looking at it with a
sense of
i'll use the word uncertainty or dare i
say dread oh this is a big
game
i've had this conversation with a lot of
athletes who are headed for the us
olympic trials
oh that's really big doc
yeah it's really big
and why the heck do you think you've
been invited to that big thing because
young lady young man you are
by definition big otherwise you would
not have been invited
so
you have to put yourself
in your own mind and heart as equal to
the arena
that you have been invited to perform in
you have to be proactive in your
game
like you know you can't treat the
olympic trials just like you treat every
other track meet
or or tennis tournament it's the big one
okay well if it's the big one
and you're in it
i guess that means you're big
so as
it's the way you look forward to those
things
that matters
i hope i hope that's clear enough
most of the people that i know that i
think have good confidence are excitable
you know they're curious they're
genuinely enthusiastic about what it is
that's to come
and in the times when i see myself in
the best states are when i am genuinely
excited about the opportunity to do
something and there's a bit of
trepidation in there but if
if excitement is pretty high i think
that usually ends up counteracting any
of the dreads and the worry and the
concern that you have
very very much so um
excitement
you know you think about that in terms
of just your
body's
energy level and your body's sort of
arousal
oh excited my my heart's pounding my uh
feet and hands are a little bit twitchy
um i can feel sort of jumpy
okay i'm excited
some people would look at those same
physical
changes my heart's beating fast i'm a
little bit jumpy as oh my gosh i'm
nervous fear yeah yeah oh my gosh i'm
nervous as opposed to
whoa i'm excited it's the same
physiology
the same biology
but it's your
interpretation thereof
that can make the difference as to
whether you feel
positive eager or doubtful and worried
isn't it isn't it insane that the story
that we tell ourselves the framing that
we put around the situation
literally changes
the our interpretation of what the same
stimulus
is you know
indeed good a good example of you go
into the gym you finish your workout
you're sweaty and
gasping for air and lying on the floor
and that's the reason that you go in
right that that feeling is satisfaction
that's the purpose for you going into
the gym but if that happened
spontaneously as you were sat in the car
at a set of traffic lights you would
think that something terrible was
happening to you and yet it is exactly
the same sensation you know one of them
would be you ringing people saying come
and get me i need to go to the hospital
the other one is you high-fiving your
friends in 30 seconds time saying what a
good workout so
it is almost all about framing almost
exclusively
almost exclusively um we all have had
the experience of the butterflies in the
stomach and the heart pounding fast as
we are about to enter
a competitive or performance situation
and it doesn't matter if that situation
is one of your choosing
i choose to play a sport or it's a
requirement i have to take that
statistics mid-term in order to proceed
through my engineering
course sequence at university
i have to be in this performance
situation i choose to be in this
performance situation and in
right as we enter those moments our
bodies are designed to
undergo a biochemical shift
to produce more energy so that we can be
good in the presence of those demands so
that we can indeed perform well there is
an enabling biochemical shift
the side effects of which
are your stomach flips up and down and
your heart beats
louder and faster
and your palm sweat a little bit and you
get a little bit twitchy
now
isn't it nice that your body produces
this energy surge before you're about to
do something that matters
let's make sure that we interpret it
that we frame it constructively oh wow
my body's turning on it's getting more
energy that means i'm going to be
better in this test that means i'm going
to be better in this match as opposed to
oh wow my stomach's flipping up and down
my heart is pounding what the heck is
the matter with me
well there's nothing the matter with you
this is the way the animal is designed
to operate this is a legacy again from
our thousands of years hundreds of
thousands of years of developmental
evolution it's a survival mechanism it's
great that our body does this let's look
forward to
that arousal let's look forward to the
pounding heart and the butterflies
because it tells us that our body is
doing what is helpful for us
so that we can be good at something that
is important to us
what a nice thing that your body does
for you let's look forward to it and
appreciate it
what did you learn from lady gaga
i learned from lady gaga
basically the power
of that kind of delusion that we were
speaking about earlier
you know before she was an international
star
she reports
that she would walk down the street
feeling as if she was a star me acting
as if she was a star singing out loud
and she really feels that it was that
period of
let's call it constructive delusion
that enabled her to feel good when it
came time to record under pressure under
a deadline to perform under the
spotlight and she advises us all okay
you should
go ahead and be delusional about
yourself go ahead and lie to yourself
about where you are and how you are and
then fight hard to make that lie the
truth
i think that is a wonderful
statement go ahead and dream big
in a way lying to yourself but then get
down to business and fight like hell
don't just dream it
dream it for sure
but then do the things do the work
study your instrument study your craft
fight like hell
to make that lie
that delusion the actuality the truth
great lesson what's your thoughts on
people that use uh personas and have
different identities i think beyonce had
a
queen
i'm gonna get this wrong queen bee or
something i know that is it kobe bryant
that's got mamba mamba mentality what's
your thoughts on uh players and
performers that almost step into another
person
i think they're just finding a way
to express the full extent of their
talent
when kobe bryant became the black mamba
you know
that was his in a way acknowledgement
of his natural talent and all the work
that he put in
so it's a it i see it as a way of of
affirming oneself
and
i've had many athletes under my uh two
religion supervision over the years
kind of develop their own
competitive
game day
personality you know the bounty hunter
that's what i turned into on game day
okay um i
morph from
being and they have to do this here at
west point they more from being a polite
respectful
modest
in a way very self-conscious individual
because here at west point every cadet
is constantly
under observation
uniform
body language
verbal behavior how you
salute speak to different peoples at
different levels of the chain of command
so you have to have that
aspect of your personality
but you get to take that uniform off
when you step into your locker room and
now you're putting on the football pads
for our football team now you're putting
on the wrestling singlet now you're
tightening the chin strap tightening the
shoes and in so doing you are becoming
the bounty hunter
the relentless ass kicker
the national champion at 149 pounds or
whatever it is so i absolutely support
and delight that um
yeah
and acknowledge yourself as you want to
be
is there a
issue with integrating that self back
into the normal person are there any
lessons that are potentially lost
when you do partition off the performing
self and the normal self is there a
degree of integration and lesson
learning that can move between the two
that those people perhaps are missing
out on
well if you continue to maintain your
competitive game day persona
after the game is over and you bring
that back to your family you bring that
back to um your
quote unquote normal life well sure
that's a mistake
so just as you have a ritual to bring
yourself to
your personal equivalent of black mamba
or the bounty hunter
you also have a ritual that brings you
back
from that you taking off the competitive
uniform
you're putting on
the civilian clothes so is ritual a big
part of this as far as you can see
i use the term routine
because you are in control of a routine
a ritual tends to be in control of you
so there is definitely a routine
to enter the arena
there's subroutines to stay within your
desired persona during the performance
and then there is a routine
to
let go of that persona and
re-enter the
quote-unquote normal world
so yeah you get to manage both those
situations
the entering the maintaining and then
the re-entry
back so that you can be the polite
modest
enjoyable person to be around
because let's face it if you're in that
black mamba
boy
you can be
you can be very competitive but you
won't have too many friends
yeah in that personality um
the wonderful television series ted
lasso
there's a character i'm forgetting his
name he was the former captain
of
the hounds
who
kind of maintained that surly
personality
in the broadcast booth which got him in
trouble
and then uh outside basically
encouraging his young niece
to be a little bit obnoxious with his
language i'm sorry i'm not remembering
the character's name but he was one of
my favorite characters and he eventually
learned that hey
what helped me on the soccer pitch
that kind of determination and ferocity
maybe i don't want to have that in other
aspects of my life
are there any pursuits or any daily
practices that you think we've missed
off that people should try and add into
their routines
and i think we've covered a lot of the
important points
what i would just stress
is that
you're gonna have to make these choices
about how you think about yourself
during
the good moments in your life and during
the not so good moments in my in your
life um one of the concluding stories in
my book comes from a man who
retired as a four-star general in the
united states army and he told a story
of basically the worst day of his life
when he was in iraq and a suicide bomber
detonated
the explosive vest
in a mess hall where he was seated
and a number of the soldiers under his
command died
and he very very nearly was killed
himself
that was the worst day of his life but
he had to continue
to execute missions
despite that
very bad setback that disaster that
tragedy
so as he put it faith takes practice
you have to do this even in your worst
moments
perhaps that is a not particularly
pleasant thought
to conclude with
but i don't want anybody to feel that
this is all sunshine lollipops and
rainbows
constructive thinking
to help one become certain
takes place
during the good times takes place during
the bad times and it's probably more
important that you have that
constructive thinking process during
setbacks even during as the general put
it the worst day of your life but you
always have the choice to do that and if
you make the right choice that worst day
of your life
probably won't repeat itself
dr nate zinser ladies and gentlemen the
confident mind a battle tested guide to
unshakable performance will be linked in
the show notes below if people want to
keep up to date with the other stuff
that you do where should they go
um natesensor.com is my personal website
i'd love to be in contact with tons of
your listeners my pleasure today's been
awesome nate we made it
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace